thank you squarespace for sponsoring
this video todo is one of the strongest
smartest and most controversial
characters in jutsu kaisen he has
a ridiculously fast-paced character arc
and goes from brutal
borderline berserker to charming gentle
giant in
under three episodes he has a
self-proclaimed iq
of 530 000 judges people based on the
type of woman manages to creepy tadouri
out which
is a real feat and on top of that with
boogie woogie has one of the most
fascinating powers in the story
[Music]
in this video you will learn everything
there is to know about total how strong
he is
how smart he is that his awesome voice
actor is actually german
i know the hell and of course the hidden
genius behind his philosophy
and design as a character that make him
one of the most loved characters by fans
and one of the most disliked characters
in the story this is the character
analysis of
aoi
[Music]
okay
okay let's get the elephant out of the
room as in let's talk about the
elephants
remember how these guys are all supposed
to be high schoolers well todo looks
like a 20 year old philosophy student
a truckload of protein powder now i
think about it that actually sums up his
personality pretty perfectly as well
in terms of power akutami introduces
toto as a realistic measuring stick for
itadori and cole
someone who is a whole level or two
above them but
more in reach than the walking and
talking calamity that is satoru gojo
hold on
in fact todo is undoubtedly one of the
if not
the strongest among the current students
and yes fushigoro doing a kamikaze
attack doesn't count despite being
only a second year student toto is
already a full-fledged first grade
sorcerer
just so you have some comparison that is
the same grade as nanami or yaga who is
a school
principal as if this wasn't enough
however most of the time
todo doesn't even use his extraordinary
cursed ability but
simply raw physical strength not only
does he have a ridiculous amount of
brute power but
is also surprisingly agile
when things turn dark however which
pretty much only means special great
kind of dark
toto unpacks his innate due to ability
the boogie woogie that allows him to
switch the position of anything with
cursed energy within his range with a
clap of his hands for instance he can
change himself out with the location of
another person
or switch two different objects other
than himself as well
[Music]
now is this technique ridiculously
powerful
obviously but i want you to appreciate
for a moment what an
unusual match up this power is for a
hulk-like guy like total because once
again here
as you know from my other videos akutami
absolutely loves playing with
expectations
usually the trope of the beefcake
character in anime is kind of
predictable either he's a lot weaker and
more stupid
than all the weak looking people around
him
or he gets a boring power like making
his body harder or having a big weapon
or something basically that's the enemy
guy who always goes down first
the idea here being that we as the
audience go ooh he looks strong just how
will our skinny hero beat them
and then we're super surprised or
whatever how powerful the small guy
actually is let's be honest this trope
was basically dead after david vs
goliath but it
keeps coming back for some reason
anyways toto flips that trope on its
head in the sense that
he looks incredibly strong and he
actually is incredibly strong
and not only that he also has an ability
that requires him to basically play
4d chats with his opponent all the time
trying to figure out if
what when and where he's gonna switch
a buff dude who is actually buff and has
an elegant ability that requires some
brains
hey anime industry was it really that
hard to come up with that sort of
character because on top of his power
oh boy toto is a pretty sharp cookie
not sure if he's 530 000 iq points type
of sharp
as he likes to claim but he's definitely
no dummy either
so let's talk about todo's big brain and
what exactly is going on in there so
that we can get
to as different sounding exclamations
from him
as this
let's is about toto's personality but
first
a break real quick i want to say thank
you to squarespace who's the sponsor of
this video
thank you squarespace i've made content
on youtube for over two years now and
can codes
could coach and still designing my own
website has always been a super daunting
task for me coming up with all the
functionalities i wanted to have
creating a functioning design from
scratch coding to bring it all to life
web design is really hard the reason i
like squarespace is that it lets you
build your own personal website
super easily they have a ton of
wonderfully designed web design
templates that you can customize
to create your very own professional
looking website
with no prior knowledge head over to
squarespace.com to try it out for free
and once you're ready to launch use my
link in the description below to get 10
of your first purchase of a website or
domain
[Music]
out of all the things to love about
total my favorite thing is probably the
way he gets introduced into the story
basically akutami hits us with all the
worst parts of his personality to paint
this picture of
a blood hungry idiot who judges people
based on the taste of women
which he does but as you will see
surprisingly there is
a lot more behind this anyway so after
basically beating maego me into a pulp
for having a decent view of women
we get a pretty rapid turnaround for his
character
first we see him going against a plan to
assassinate yuji
basically having as little respect for
his classmates and teachers as fomegomi
nice well still no reason to like him i
guess
but at least we get that this man acts
based on his own principle
and isn't just a dick to megumi for the
sake of it and then of course we get his
interaction with itadore and
oh boy it's no surprise that these two
click
after making up a completely fake
flashback in his head that has
more plot development than most regular
anime do toto
suddenly sees itadore as his best
friends
and from then on mentors yuji and brings
him to a completely
different level within a mere number of
minutes
suddenly turning him into an absolute
fan favorites
oh and can we talk about the fact that
toto got rejected in his own fantasy
and chose itadori over his love interest
what a true bro
thanks bro hey we're bros bro now we
don't really know if these fake memories
have
something to do with yuji or whether
they simply are part of toto's quirky
personality
as i personally like to think after all
in his fight with hanami
toto has an entire imaginary tactical
meeting with his favorite pop idol in
the blink of a
seconds
[Music]
so i think that crafting a made-up
backstory for some of the few people he
can actually respect in this world
next to anyone who's stronger than him
which is basically
all the special grades i guess is very
much in character for total
and i think it's this that proves just
how smart a cookie he actually is
after all i think you will find it
pretty hard to describe this creative
ability together with the ridiculously
fast analytical information
processing he has as anything but
intelligence
on top of all this todo is an extremely
smart and dexterous fighter when he has
to
immediately unpacking his curse
technique to its fullest against hanami
after realizing that this is an enemy
that he cannot beat with power alone
however this sort of intelligence well
without any doubt
impressive pales in comparison to the
part of toto's character that i find
truly impressive his abs i'm just
kidding the truly impressive part about
toto is
actually his philosophy and approach to
the central moral
question of the story that makes him one
of the most wise looking characters in
the story
answer to what makes a good life worth
living
is basically existentialism while just
like nanami omahito he
understands that life doesn't have
meaning in itself and that very much in
the buddhist way of thinking
everything is fleeting todo also
believes that people are capable of
making their own purpose
and find a reason to love and embrace
life
his clear understanding of the natural
world even gives him a better
understanding of the flow of cursed
energy
and other than marito for example who as
i explained in my last video
wants to fully embrace his nature and
instincts todo gives yuji
agency by telling him to yes except
being part of nature but also having his
own will by swallowing his anger
so basically toto is someone who fights
against the natural order of things for
the sake of the love that he feels for
other people
he even fights hanami who literally is
an embodiment of nature
in fact as ironic as it might seem
believe me
i know love is actually the big theme
behind toto's character
so much so that akutami even draws his
cursed energy
as taking the form of little hearts love
in general is a very prominent theme and
due to
kaisen that often is contrasted with the
curses
[Music]
however what appears as comical and over
the top on the outside when toto
suddenly treats yuji as if they'd known
each other since birth
is actually total embracing his
friendship and sudden brotherly love for
yuji
as one of the driving factors in his
life just as his love for takada
and even though they aren't real to
total they are and they give him meaning
and happiness
not by accident but by choice
and even his seemingly macho-like habit
of judging people based on that type of
partner
gets twisted on its head when we learn
that he isn't just a superficial douche
but actually has inherited this quirk as
well as his philosophy
from this mysterious motorcycle woman
that we meet in his flashback and so i
believe what toto
actually does by asking this question is
figuring out whether or not people can
actually
state their true feelings and know what
they love
i don't think it's that everyone needs
to love jennifer lawrence
it's that yuji has no issue saying what
he loves
while megumi does though i think you
agree that it might be a bit over the
top punching him into the ground for
this
the fact that not everyone is able to
state clearly what they love
or even know what they love is something
toto has to learn to understand
his basic need as a character as a
result i think that toto is written as a
twist on the trope that strong
guys are always stupid and for some
reason weak
making him one of the strongest and
wisest characters in the story
while still being as batshit crazy as
the rest of them are
[Music]
he is one of the central guides to
itadore's growth and without any doubt
part of the relationships that yuji will
someday have to discover as his true
source of meaning and happiness in life
in short pretty much as most characters
are jutsu kaisen
aoi todo might as well be the main
character
like maki or for shiguro he's pretty
much peak
shonen protagonist material and that's
what makes him
such a lovable character
what better way to continue than talk
about todo's major enemy in the story
both
physically and philosophically
watch my analysis of hanami an
absolutely fascinating character by
clicking right here
or check out my other due to kaizen
character analysis here
thanks for watching peace